one of the great mysteries
still to be addressed by philosophy
is why is it that numbers
which are after all constructs of the
human mind
why is it that numbers are
so incredibly powerful for the
description of
nature nature after all
is somehow given we find it all around
us
and numbers arise in the depths of human
racial nation so what is the
relationship
of these things to each other this is
it may appear to be an
easy question it's such a difficult
question
that it wasn't even asked in philosophy
until the 20th century
it's very puzzling
and i think that it indicates a
fundamental congruency
between processes that are mental
and the structure of the world itself
when we look into ourselves
we discover the same patterns
that we discover in the birth and death
of a species the flow of a river
the collapse of a corporation or the
flowering of a love affair
it's the process is somehow
under the aegis of a kind of universal
equation of description so it doesn't
matter whether it's the birth and death
of your hope
or the rise and fall of the assyrian
empire
or the evolution of the pacific ocean
processes always occur in the same way
and this is why there is congruence
between the mental world of human beings
and the world of abstract mathematics
and the world of nature
these things are as it were simply
different
levels of condensation
of the same universal stuff
this is why the concept of truth
can have some meaning i mean
when you think about it truth
why should it even be possible for us
as monkeys to entertain that notion
where is it writ large that
mammals traveling in packs should have
any relationship to truth
whatsoever and yet the faith is
that somehow thinking means something
it's not just something we do
it means something it means something
because there is
sufficient freedom within the human
system
to be both right or wrong
and this right or wrong lays upon us the
obligation of
mirroring nature in models which we
build
in our own minds now the old idea in
science
was that these mathematical models of
nature
were in fact laws truths
eternal platonic truths that were being
teased out
in the 20th century a slight
epistemological sophistication leads to
this word
models where we say we're modeling
reality and our model
is only as good as we need it to be
if we're trying to model the flight of
an artillery shell
the model needs to be only good enough
to get the artillery
shell to its target we don't need to
understand the essence
of lead or the nature of motion
there we simply need the model to kick
out
the data that interests us and in the
20th century it's been understood
that all knowledge is dependent upon the
question asked
and the relationship of mathematics to
nature
is one of the profound indicators
i think that truth
can be known maybe not the truth
but i always think of the positivist
philosopher wittgenstein
who was once asked in a classroom
situation about a certain proposition
is it the truth and he said well it's
certainly
true enough and you know
that's where we are with our modeling of
the world and with our mathematics it is
the truest truth we know it is
true enough
[Music]
between the stars